رومانسي حب القوات الروسيه من الضفه
الغربيه لنهر النيبرو هذا الشهر الا انها
تقصف البلدات والقرى بما في ذلك خرس من
مواقع جديده على الضفه المقابله رئيس
الاوكراني قال ان القوات الروسيه قصفت 30
موقعا في اقليم خرسا خلال اسبوع
واحد فقط قصف العدو 30 موقعا
ممكن
الكهربائي النوويه وبعد تصريحا لرئيس شركه
الطاقه النوويه الاوكرانيه قال فيه ان
هناك مؤشرات على ان القوات الروسيه ربما
تستعد لاخلاء المحطه نفى المتحدث باسم
الكريم ايه خطط للانسحاب الروسي منها
ولا يمكن ان توجد
هيئه الطاقه النوويه الروسيه ودعت الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه التابعه للامم
المتحده مرارا لوقف الاعمال العسكريه
بالمحطه والمنطقه المحيطه بها للحيلوله
دون وقوع كارثه نوويه